So I have to leave you in the middle
of something. Yeah, pretty exciting.
So I'll come back and take it from there.
So what does it do you have
to remember from last time,
you know what are the
main ideas I covered?
One is we took the notion of temperature
for which you have an intuitive feeling
and turn it into something
more quantitative.
So you can not only say this is harder
than that, that's harder than this.
You can say by how much
by how many degrees.
And in the end we agreed to use the
absolute Kelvin scale for temperature.
And the way to find the Kelvin scale,
you take the gas,
any gas that you like,
like hydrogen or helium or low
concentration and put that inside a
piston and cylinder,
but it occupies and volume and there's
a certain pressure by putting weights on
top and you take the product of p Times v
and the claim is for whatever gas
you take, it will be a straight line.
Remember now this is in Kelvin. You're
sending grid scale is somewhere over here.
But I've shifted the origin,
the Kelvin scale.
So somebody here will be the boiling
point of water somewhere when the freezing
point of water,
that may be the boiling point of water
and if you took a different amount of a
different gas,
you will get some other life,
but they will always be straight lines
if the concentration is sufficiently low.
In other words,
it appears that pressure
times volume is some constant,
I don't know what the colleges
c times this temperature
and you can use that to
measure temperature because
if you not two points on a
straight line,
then you know that you can find the
slope and then you can calibrate it the
monitor than for any other
value of p Times v that you get.
You can come down and
read your temperature.
That's the preferred scale and we prefer
the scale because it doesn't seem to
depend on the gas that you use. I can
use one that you can use another one,
people in another planet
who'd never heard of water.
They can use the different guests,
but all gases seemed to have the property,
the pressure times the volume is linearly
proportional with this new temperature
scale measured with this new audit in an
absolute zero that is really nothing to
the left of this t equals zero.
Next thing I mentioned was people used
to think of the theory of heat as a new
theory. You know you got
mechanics and all that stuff,
levers and pulleys and all that. Then you
had this mysterious thing called heat,
which had been around for many years,
but people started quantifying it by
saying that it's a fluid called the
calorific fluid and hot things have a
lot of it and called things have less of
it and when you mix them the calories,
some whole flows from
the heart to the cold.
Then we defined specific heat law of
conservation of this catalytic fluid that
allows you to do some
problems in calorimetry.
You make so much of this with so
much of that. Where will they end up?
That kind of problem.
So that promoted heat to a new,
an independent entity, different from
all of the things we have studied,
but something such as that.
It is not completely alien or new
concert because that seems to be a
conservation law for this heat because
the heat lost by the quarter Walker was
the heat gained by the hot water.
Sorry, he'd gained by the cold water.
It was the heat loss by the hot water,
so you have a conservation law.
Secondly,
we know another way to produce heat.
Instead of saying put it on the stove,
put it on the store,
in which case that is something mysterious
flowing from the stove into the water
that he'd sit up. I totally,
this is a different way.
I think you can do take two automobiles,
slammed him and go,
this is not the most economical
way to make your dinner,
but I'm just telling you as a
matter of principle by two ferries,
slammed them into each other, take this
park and put it on top and it'll heat up,
but arteries will heat up.
The question is,
what happened to the Kennedy Energy
of the two cars that is really gone.
So in the old days we would say,
well,
we don't have play the law of
conservation of energy because this is an
inelastic collisions that was an
illegal way out of the whole issue.
But you realize now this calorie fluid
can be produced from nowhere because
there was no calorie fluid before,
but slamming the two cars
produces this extra heat.
So that indicates that perhaps there's
a relation between mechanical energy and
heat energy that when mechanical energy
disappears, heat energy up peers.
So how do you do the conversion ratio?
You know,
how many calories can you get if you
sacrifice one jeweler mechanical energy.
So jewel did the experiment,
not with cars.
I mean he didn't have cars at that time.
So if he did,
you would have probably done it with cars.
He had this guy did with him,
which was a little,
uh,
shaft with some padlets
and a pulley on the top.
And you let the weight go down.
And I told you guys,
the way it goes from here to here,
the MGH laws will not be the
gain in one half MV squared.
Something will be missing. Keep track
of the missing amount. So many jewels,
but meanwhile you find
this water has become hot,
you find than how many calories should
have gone in because we know the specific
date of water,
we know the rise in temperature,
we know how many calories were produced
and then you compare the two and you
find that 4.2 jewels is
equal to one calorie.
So that is the conversion ratio
of calories to Jews. One jewel,
4.2 joules of mechanical energy.
So in the example of the in cars,
take the one half MV squared for each car,
turn it into jewels,
slammed them together.
If they come to arrest,
you've lost all of that and then you
take that and you write it as divided
before 0.2 and that's how much
calories you helped produced.
You have to card was made of just
one material it at a specific heat,
then it would go up by seven temporary.
You can actually predict.
Okay,
so today I wanted to go a little deeper
into the question of where does the
energy actually stored in the car?
I mean,
what is heat? We still don't
know in detail what he does.
We just said car heats up and the loss
of jewels do better before point to is
the gain in counties.
Now we can answer in detail
exactly what is heat.
That's what we're going
to talk about today.
Whenever you say something is hotter,
what did we mean at a microscopic level?
In the old days when people didn't
know what anything was made off,
they didn't have this understanding.
And the understanding that I'm going to
give you today is based on the simple
fact that everything is made
up of atoms that was not known,
and that's one of the greatest
discoveries. In the end,
everything is made of atoms. Then atoms
combined to form molecules and so on.
So how does that come into play for that,
I want you to take the simple example,
but the temperature enters that isn't
the donation PV equals to some constant
times temperature.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
Take some gas,
make sure it's sufficiently tight.
You would put it into this person.
Measure the weights on top of it
divided by the ATO to get the pressure.
That's the pressure. That's the
volume. The volume is the region here.
Multiply the product.
Then if you heat up the gas by
putting it on some hot plate,
you will find the product PB increases
and as the temperature increases,
PBS proportional duty. They want to ask
what this, this proportionality constant.
Suppose you were doing this in the
old days. That's what people did.
What did we think should
be on the right hand side?
What is going to control this particular
constant for your given experiment?
You know what it might be proportional to
yes, yes, I'm out of gas.
That's true because I'm out of gas at
zero. We think there is no pressure.
When you say amount of gas
as a very safe sentence, uh,
because I'm on measured in by what means?
By what metric?
Right. Suppose you were not
aware of particles then.
What would you mean by amount of gas?
Yes,
the mass. Know if you guys ever said
malls, I was going to shoot you down.
You're not supposed to know those things
we have finally did use to put yourself
back in whatever's stone ages. We
wouldn't, we don't anything else.
Mass would be reasonable argument.
Right? What's the argument?
We know that if you had some amount of
gas producing the pressure and you put
twice as much stuff, you think it
will produce twice as much pressure.
Same reason why you think the expansion
of a rod is proportionally change in
temperature times the starting length.
So at this mass is what doing it.
So it's proportional. The mass
is a video. Reasonable guess.
So if we put more gas into your best and
you think it'll produce more pressure,
that's actually correct.
So let's go to that one particular
sample in your laboratory that you did.
So put the mass that you had there.
The new should put a constant still,
I don't know what you want me
to call this constant c prime.
This constant contain everything,
but I pulled out the mass
and the remaining constant
I want to call [inaudible].
This is actually correct.
You can take a certain gas in,
it could find out what's the premise,
but here is what people
found if you do it that way.
The constant sleep prime depends
on the gas you are considering.
If you consider hydrogen gas,
that's called that c prime for hydrogen.
Somebody else puts in helium gas and
you find the seat prime for helium
is one fourth c prime for hydrogen.
If you do carbon,
it's another number c prime for carbon.
You see prime for hydro then divided by 12
so eat gas has a different constant.
So we conclude that yes it's
the mass that decides that,
but the mass has to be
divided by different numbers
for different gases to find
the real effect that has in terms
of pressure. In other words,
one gram of hydrogen and one gram of
helium do not have the same pressure.
In fact,
one game of helium has to be divided by
four to have the two finder's effect on
pressure.
So you have to think about why is it
that the mass statically is not involved.
Masters to be divided by a number.
The,
it's a nice round number four
for this and fall for that.
And of course people figured out
there's a long story I cannot go into,
but I think you all know the answer,
but now,
now you're allowed to fast forward to
the correct answer because I really don't
have the time to see
how they worked it out.
But from these integers and the way
gasses reacted informed complicated
molecules,
they figure it out.
What's really going on is that you're
dividing by a number that's proportional
to the mass of the underlying
fundamental entity,
which would be an Adam
in some cases molecule,
but I'm just going to
call everything is Adam.
So if things like carbon as Adam's
weighed 12 times as much as things called
hydrogen,
then if you took some amount of carbon,
you divided by the number like 12 to
count the number of carbon atoms in case.
Why didn't you want to count the number
of hydrogen atoms so that what really
you want here, it's not the mass, but
the number of atoms of a given kind.
We are certainly free to write either a
mass or the number of items because the
two are proportional.
But the beauty of writing it this way,
you write it in this fashion,
but this is the new constant.
K K is independent of the guests.
You want to write it in the manner in
which it doesn't depend on the gas,
right it in terms of mass if you did,
but each mass you've got to
divide by a certain number.
Then once you divided by the number,
you can put a single concert in front,
or if you want a universal constant,
what you should really be counting
the number of atoms or molecules.
So you couldn't have written it that way
until he knew about atoms and molecules
and people who were let to atoms and
molecules by it and looking at the way
gases interact. And it's a beautiful
piece of chemistry to figure it out.
Really that that are entities
which come in discrete units,
not at all obvious. Now all days that mass
comes in discrete units called Adam's,
but that's what they,
they used.
So this is called the Boltzmann constant.
The Boltzmann constant has a value of
1.4 times 10 to the minus 23 let's see
jewels,
Kelvin,
that's it.
Or
you'll just Kelman or degrees centigrade.
So this is the universal constant.
So now what people like to do is they
don't like to write the number because if
you write the number
in a typical situation,
what's the number going to be on it?
Take some random group gas, one gram,
two grams, one kilogram, it doesn't
matter the number you will put in there.
There's some number like 10
to the 23 attended the 25
that's a huge number.
So whenever a huge numbers involved,
what you try to do is to measure the
huge number as a simple multiple off.
Another huge number, which will be
our unit for measuring large numbers.
For example,
when you want to buy eggs,
you measure in dozens and
he wanted to buy paper,
even want to measure written thousands,
five hundreds or whatever the units
they sell them. And it's a natural unit.
When you want to find intergalactic
distance, as you may use a light year,
you use units. So that in that
unit, the quantity of interest was,
is some number that you can count in your
heads. When you count people's height,
you'll use feet because if something
between one and eight let's say you don't
want to use angstroms and you don't
want to use millimeters. Likewise,
when he wanted to simply count numbers,
it turns out that's a very natural
number called Avogadro's number.
Yes.
Avogadro's number is six times
10 to the 23 it has no unit.
It's simply a number and
that's called a mall.
Say more or less like a dozen.
Want it to buy six times 10
to the 23 eggs. You will say,
get me one mole of eggs, but more or less
than just a number. It's a huge number.
You can ask yourself,
what's so great about this number?
Why would someone think of this particular
number? Why not some other number?
Why not 10 to the 24
do you know what's
special about this number?
Yes,
yes.
If you like a mall is such that one
mole of hydrogen weighs one gram and
hydrogen is the simplest element.
If the nucleus is just a proton and
the electron mass it negligible.
So this if you like,
is the reciprocal of the mass of hydrogen.
Other words,
one over Avogadro's number,
just the mass of hydrogen in grams
of a hydrogen atom
in grams.
So you basically say,
I want to call it this large number.
So let me take one gram,
which is my normal unit.
You're thinking in grams.
Then I ask how many hydrogen atoms?
There's one gram of hydrogen contain.
That's the number.
That's the mall.
So if you decide to measure the number
of atoms you have in a given problem in
terms of this number, you write it as
some other small number called malls,
titans,
the number in a mall,
and you are free to write it this way.
If you write it this way,
the new write,
this n r t o is the universal gas constant
times the Boltzmann constant and
zero times the Boltzmann constant.
That happens to be 8.3 joules per
degree centigrade or per Kelvin,
right? The units were odd
will be Pv, which is you
understand energy divided by t
in terms of calories.
I remember this nice known number
two calories per degree centigrade
degrees centigrade and Calvin are
the same. The origins are shifted,
but when you go up at one
degree in San Diego or Kelvin,
you go with the same or
more than temperature.
So this is what they found out first
because they didn't know anything about
atoms and so on.
But later on when you go look under
the hood of what the gas is made of,
if you write it in terms of the number of,
if you write it in terms of
the number of actual atoms,
you should use the Lidl k or you can
write it in terms of number of malls,
in which case use
big r
and the relation between
the two is simply this.
If you're thinking of a gas and how
many moles of gas do I have? Exactly.
One gram of hydrogen would be one more.
Then you will use our,
if you've gone right down to fundamentals
and say how many items do I have a new
put that here you would multiply
it by this very tiny number.
All right.
No. You start with this law and
you asked the following question.
On the left hand side is the quantity
p Times v or the right hand side?
I have an rt but let me
write it now as an Katie,
you guys should be able to go back and
forth between writing in terms of number
of moles or the number of atoms.
You like this because all numbers
here will be small of order.
One artist a number like what?
Eight in some units and it
will be one or two malls here.
This and it will be huge number like
10 to the 23 k will be a tiny number,
like 10 to the minus 23 I think in
terms of atoms, that's what you do.
Big Numbers, small constants of
think of malls, small numbers,
I mean moderate numbers and
moderate value of constantly.
We want to ask ourselves,
is that a microscopic
basis for this equation?
In other words, do we,
once you believe in atoms,
do we understand why that is
a pressure at all in a gas?
That's what we are going
to think about now.
So for this purpose we
will take a cube of gas.
It is,
this is a cube of site l by El by l,
okay.
Inside this as guests and has got some
pressure and I want to know what's the
value of the pressure you got?
Ask yourself why is that pressure?
Remember I told you what pressure means.
If you take this face of the cube for
example, it's got to be nailed down,
but the other phases,
otherwise it does come flying out
because the gas is pushing you out.
The pressure is the force on
this face divided by area.
So somebody inside is trying to get out.
Those guys are the molecules or the atoms
and what they're doing is constantly
bouncing off the wall and every
time this one bounces on a wall,
it's momentum changes from
that to the other one.
So who's changing the
momentum of the wall?
Changing the momentum is reversing that.
For example,
if you bones head on and go back,
your momentum is reversed.
Okay?
That means you push the wall
with some force in the wall,
pushes you back with the opposite force
is the force that you exerted on the
wall that I'm interested in.
I wanted to find the force on the wall.
Say this particular phase,
you can find the pressure on any phase.
It's going to be the same answer.
I'm going to take the shaded faced.
Find the pressure on it.
No.
If you want to ask, what is the
force exerted by me on anybody?
I know the forest is rate
of change of momentum
because that is d by Dt of Mv and Msa
constant and that just DVD t we just at
me, I'm just using the old f equals m a
but I'm writing it is rate of change the
momentum.
No,
I have an molecules are an Adams
randomly moving inside the box.
Each center's own direction. Suffering
collisions with the box bouncing off,
uh, like a billiard ball would at the end
of the pool table going to another wall
and doing it.
That's a very complicated problem.
So we're going to simplify the problem.
The simplification is going to be,
we're going to assume that one third of
the molecules are moving from left to
right.
One third are moving up and down and
one third are moving in and out of the
blackboard.
If Batali make an assumption that the
molecules have simply moving into three
primary directions, of course you
will have to give equal number.
It needs directions, nothing in the gas
that favors how does onto the vertical.
In reality, of course, you must admit
the fact they move in all directions,
but the simplified derivation happens
to give all the right physics.
I'm going to use that.
So an over three molecules are going
back and forth between this wall and this
wall. I'm showing you the side view.
The wall itself, it looks like this.
The molecule just got back and forth.
Next assumption,
all the molecules at the same
speed I'm going to call me.
That also is a gross and crude
description of the problem,
but I'm going to do that
anyway and see what happens.
So now you ask yourself the following
question. Take one particular molecule.
When it hits the wall and it bounces back,
it's momentum changes
from MV the minus MD.
Therefore the change in momentum is to MV.
How often does that change take place?
You guys should think about that first.
How often will collision take place?
Once you hit the wall here, you got
to go the other wall and come back.
So you've got to go a distance to
l and you're going at a speed v.
The time it takes you to l
over be the belt that be over.
Delta t is two l divided by V that
gives me and B squared over l.
That is the force due to one molecule.
That's the average force.
Realize it's not a continuous forest.
Monica hit the wall.
That's a little four 16th between the two.
Then there's nothing. Then you wait till
it comes back and hits a wall again.
If that were the real,
if that were the only thing going on,
what you would find is the wall once
the time has no pressure and suddenly it
has a lot of pressure and then
suddenly nothing. But fortunately,
this is not the only molecule that
are roughly 10 the 23 guys pounding
themselves against the wall.
So at any given instant,
even if returned the minus five seconds,
that'd be a large number
of molecules colliding.
That's the way the forest will appear to
be steady rather than a shotgun noise.
It looked very steady cause somebody at
other, we'll be pushing against the wall.
So if you ask,
know how many molecules,
this is the force due
to one molecule before,
it's due to all of them will be an over
three times and B squared over there
and over three because
of the end molecules,
a third of them were
moving in this direction.
You realize the other two
directions are parallel to the wall.
They don't apply force on the
wall to apply a force in the wall.
You gotta be moving perpendicular
to the wall. But example,
if the plates that walls are coming out
of the blackboard moving in and out of
the blackboard doesn't produce a force
in this wall that produces the force and
the other two phases.
So as far as any one set of
faces is concerned in one plane,
only the motion orthogonal talking
to that is going to contribute.
That's why you have an over
three little bit almost done.
That's the average force. If you want,
I can denote average by some f bar.
Then what about the average pressure?
The average pressure is the average
force divided by the area of that phase f
over l square.
That gives me an over three
M v squared over l cubed.
Oh,
this is very nice because LQB
just the volume of my box.
So I take the Lq, which is
ego, the volume of my box,
and I send it to the other side,
right it as PV equals and
over three M v squared.
This is what the microscopic theory tells
you.
Microscopic data says if your molecules
have all have a single speed that moving
randomly in space so that a third of them
are moving back and forth against that
wall and this wall.
Then this is the product PB.
Experimentally you find
Pv is equal to n k t
so you've compared the two
expressions and outcomes.
One of the most beautiful results which
is that NV squared over two is three
over to Katie.
Oh that guy deserves a box cause
look what it's telling you.
It's a really profound formula.
It tells you for the first time real
microscopic meaning of temperature.
What you and I call the temperature of
a gas is simply up to these factors.
Three over two k simply the
candidate energy of the molecules.
That's what temperature is.
If you've got a gas and you put your
hand into the furnace and it hot,
the temperature you're measuring
is directly the kinetic
energy of the molecules.
That is a great insight
into what temperature means.
Remember, this is not true. If
t is measured in centigrade,
if t but measured in Centigrade
I freezing point of water,
MV squared would vanish,
but that's not what's in play.
You should be measured from absolute zero.
It also tells you why absolute zero
is absolute. As you call your gas,
the kinetic energy of molecules are
decreasing and decreasing and decreasing,
but you cannot go below not moving at
all. Right? That's the lowest possible.
Kennedy, Kennedy. That's why it's
absolute zero. At that point,
everybody stops moving. That's
why you have no pressure. No.
These results that are modified
by the laws of quantum mechanics,
but we don't have to worry about that
now in the classical physics is actually
correct to say that when the temperature
goes to zero, all motion Caesar's,
Oh, this is the picture that I want you
to bear in mind when you say temperature.
Absolutely.
Temperature is a measure of molecular
agitation more precisely up to the
constant k three over two k.
The kinetic energy of a molecule is the
absolute temperature. That's part I gas.
If it took a solid and you say,
what happens when I heat the
solid Bellis got a question. Yes.
Just out of curiosity,
why
did they said divide both sides by two?
Just it.
You would divide by two because one half
MV squared is a family at a quantity,
namely Kennedy.
Granted that's what you divide by two
not the thing to notice is that every gas,
whatever is made off at a given
temperature as a given Kennedy energy,
because the Kennedy energy per molecule
on the left hand side is dependent
absolute temperature and nothing else.
So at certain degrees,
like 300 Kelvin hydrogen Kennedy going
to do to be the same carbon Kennedy
energy, but also be the same. The
Kennedy Kennedy will be the same,
not the velocity.
The carbon atom is heavier.
It'll be moving slow,
but at that temperature in order
to have the same candidate again,
so all molecules,
all gases at a given temperature,
all I'll atoms,
let me say,
I'd give given temperature engages
farm will have the same Kennedy got it.
No.
If you have a solid,
what's the different between
the gas into a solid and a gas?
The Adams said moving anywhere
they want in the box in a solid,
every atom has a place.
If you take a two dimensional solid,
the atoms look like this,
they form a lattice or an array.
That's because you will find out that
this is more advanced stuff that every
atom plants itself in a
potential that looks like this.
You imagine on the ground you make these
hollows low points. The low potential,
high point high potential. Obviously
if you put a bunch of objects here,
they will sit at the bottom
of these little concave holds.
You've dug in the ground at zero degrees,
absolute all items that sit at the
bottom of that allotted positions.
That'd be a solid at zero temperature,
so in a solid,
everybody has a location.
I've shown you one dimensional solid,
but you can imagine a three dimensional
solid where in a lattice of three
dimensional points there's an assigned
place for [inaudible] and it sits there.
If you heat up that solid. Now what
happens is these guys start vibrating.
Now here is where your knowledge of
simple harmonic motion to come into play.
When you take a system in equilibrium,
it'll execute simple harmonic motion.
If you give it a real kick,
if you put it on top of a hot plate,
the atoms in the hot plate, we'll bump
into these guys and start the movie.
They will start vibrating.
So a hot solid is one in which the
atoms that making more and more violent
isolations around their
assigned positions,
the hit the more and more and more.
Eventually you start doing this,
you go all the way from here to here.
That is nothing to prevent you
from rolling over to the next site.
Once you jumped the fence and
take up a bunch of houses, okay,
all hole in the ground,
you're living in a hole in the ground.
You as you get agitated,
you're able to do more and
more oscillation silicon
rollover to the next house.
Once that happens,
all hell breaks loose because you don't
have any reason to stay where you are.
You start going everywhere.
What do you think that is?
Pardon me? That's melting.
That's the definition of melting.
Nothing is when you can leap
over this potential barrier,
potential energy barrier,
go to the next site.
The next side is just like this site.
If you can jump that fence,
you can jump this one.
You go everywhere and you melt.
That's the process of melting.
And once you have a liquid,
atoms don't have a different location.
Now between the liquid and a solid, uh,
this is, this is clear, different but
in liquid and the vapor is more subtle.
So I don't want to go into that.
But at some point, uh, liquids,
if you look at a liquid locally,
it will look very much like a solid,
the sense that interrupt tomic spacing
just very tightly constrained in liquid,
a solid. If I know I'm here, I know if I
go 100 times the basic lattice spacing,
there'll be another person sitting there
that's called a long range order in the
liquid. I cannot say that liquid.
I can say my, I'm here locally.
The environment around me is known.
But if you go a few hundred miles,
I cannot tell you are precise location.
If some mother Adam will be there or not.
So we sell liquid, a short
rain position, a lottery,
but not long grain daughter and
a gas has no auditor at all.
If I tell you there's a gas molecule here,
I cannot tell you about anybody else's.
We, nobody has any assigned location.
Okay, so this is the big city should
have off temperature temperatures,
agitated motion, either motion in the
vicinity of where you're told to sit.
You feel it in a solid motion all over
the box with more than more candidate
candidate.
The next thing in this category
teacher is that certainly not true.
That third of the molecules are moving
back and forth. We know that's a joke,
right? Right now I'm in this
room. There's no reason on earth.
Third of the molecules are
doing this and others are doing.
That's an approximation had
moving in random directions.
So if we really got the stomach for it,
you should do a pressure calculation in
which you assume the molecules of random
velocities sprinkled in all directions
and after all the hard work turn said,
you will get exactly this answer.
So that's one thing I didn't want her to.
What's something I should point out
to you is the following. So supplies,
they give you a gas at 300 Kelvin.
You go and you take this formula literally
and you calculate from it a certain
one half MV squared.
If you knew the mass of the items says
hybrid and we know the mass of hydrogen,
then you find the velocity and you say,
okay,
this man tells me that anytime a cat,
a hydrogen atom,
it'll have this velocity at 300
Kelvin if I have a random direction.
But he tells me that the velocity squared,
take the square root of that.
That's the velocity it seems to us in
a unique velocity to each temperature.
Well,
that's not correct.
Not only are the molecules
moving in random directions,
they're also moving with
essentially all possible velocities.
In fact that a many,
many possible velocities and this velocity
I'm getting in this formula is some
kind of average velocity or the most
popular one are the most common one.
So if you'd really go to a gas and you
had the ability to look into it and see
what each velocity, what's the
probability that I get that velocity?
The pics that I have given you is the
probability is zero except that this one
magical velocity controlled
by the temperature,
but the real graph looks like this.
It has a certain peak.
I likes to have a certain value.
So if you had even know
enough about statistics,
you know there's a most probable value,
there's medium,
there's a mean value that
our different definitions,
they will all vary by factors of water
one but the average Kenetech energy will
obey this condition.
Yes,
got it. Great. In their gaps,
I, it's not really a Gaussian because
if I draw the nature of this curve,
it looks like B square you to
the minus M v squared over two k.
T
that's the graph I'm trying to dry here.
So it look like a ghost into the vicinity
of this, but it's kind of skewed.
It's forced to vantage of the audition
and it's not peaked at the equal
to zero real a Gaussian peaks.
At this point would be some metric
is not symmetric advantage to see it.
An advantage does infinity.
This is called the Maxwell
Boltzmann distribution. You
don't have to remember it.
Any names that just the detailed
property of what's happening in a gas,
so a temperature does not
pick a unique velocity,
but it picks this graph.
If you vary your temperature,
look at what you have to do.
If you change the number t here,
if you doubled the value of t,
that means you,
if you double the value of
bees where here and there,
the graph will look the same for every
temperature there is a certain shape.
Do go to your temperature.
It'll look more or less the same,
but it may be peaked at a different
velocity if you go to higher temperature,
no, this is another thing I want to
tell you. If you took a box containing,
not atoms but just radiation,
other words go inside a pizza oven,
take out all the air,
but the oven is still hot and the
walks or the almond not radiating
electromagnetic radiation.
Electromagnetic radiation comes in
different frequencies and you can ask how
much energy is contained in
every possible frequency range.
You know, each frequency is
a color, so you know that.
So how much energy is in the red,
how much is in the blue.
That graph also looks like this.
That's a more complicated law
called the plaque distribution.
That law also has a shape,
completely determined by temperature
is what happens.
The ship is determined by temporary that
as well as the mass of the molecules.
In the case of radiation,
it determined fully by temperature
and the velocity of light.
You give me a temperature and I will draw
you another one of these roughly bell
shaped curves. As you heat up the
furnace, the shape will change.
So again,
our temperature for radiation means a
particular of energies at each frequency
for a gas.
That means our distribution of velocities.
No, that is, has anybody seen that in
the news lately or have heard about this?
Pardon me?
I bought this particular graph.
What radiation?
The probability at each frequency of
finding radiation of that frequency in a
furnace of some temperature.
T
yes,
no, but in current news
in the last few years,
what people did was the following is
one of the predictions of the Big Bang
theory that the universe was formed some
14 and a half billion years ago and at
the early stages the temperature of
the University of some incredibly high
degrees than acid expanded the universe
schooled and today at the current size
it has got a certain average temperature
which is a remnant of the big bang
and that temperature means that is we
are sitting in a furnace up the big bang,
but the furnace, the school, the
lock over the billions of years,
the temperature of the universe is,
I don't three degrees Kelvin
and the way you determine that is
you point your telescope in the sky,
of course you're going to
get light from this star,
you're going to get late from that.
Start ignoring all the pointy things and
look at the smooth background and age
should be the same in all directions
and plot that radiation and noticed they
use satellites to plot that and you get
a perfect fit for this kind of furnace.
Radiation are called blackbody radiation
and you read the temperature by taking
that graph and fitting
into a graph like this,
but there'll be a temperature
in the case of light.
This won't be velocity squared but
there'll be the frequency square,
but read off the temperature that'll
make this work and that's what gives you
3.1 or something. You get
three degrees Kelvin. In fact,
the data point for that,
if you've got that in your lab and you
will be definitely busted for forging
your data because it's a perfect fit.
The blackbody radiation,
one of the most perfect fits to the
black body radiation is the background
radiation for the Big Bang
and there's isotropic meaning.
It's the same in all directions and this
is one of the predictions of the big
bang is that there'll be the remnant
of the black body radiation. Again,
it tells you that's a sense in which the,
if you go to intergalactic space,
that is your temperature,
that's the temperature to get for free.
They're all living in that heat. Pat
At three degrees. You want more heat,
you got to light up your furnace,
but this is everywhere in the universe
that heat left over from creation.
Okay,
that's a very,
very interesting subject.
No Lot of new physics is coming out by
looking at just that black body radiation
because the radiation
that's coming to your,
I left those stars long ago,
so what do you see today is not what's
happening today is what happened long ago
when the radiation left
that part of the universe.
Therefore we can actually tell
something about the universe,
not only now but earlier periods and
that's the way in which we can act.
Will you tell whether the universe is
saying yes expanding or not expanding or
is it accelerating in its expansion?
Or you can even say once it was
decelerating and nobody's accelerating,
all that information comes by being able
to look at the radiation from the big
bang.
What for you guys?
I think the most interesting thing is
that when you od in thermal equilibrium
and you are living in
a certain temperature,
then the radiation in your world and
the molecules and atoms in your work,
we'll have a distribution of frequencies
and velocities given by that universal
graph.
Now in our class,
we will simplify life and replace this
graph with the huge peak at a certain
velocity by pretending
everybody's at that velocity,
we will treat the whole gas as separate
representative by single average number.
So when someone says find
the velocity of molecules,
they parking board the average velocity,
you know statistically that is the
distribution of answers and an avid dance.
Here's the average is what you
wouldn't you and I have to know,
namely one half MV squared is
three half skatey on average.
Okay? No, I'm going to study in detail.
They're more than Amex.
So the system,
I'm going to study Islam only one.
We all study,
which is an ideal gas
sitting inside at Vista,
okay?
It's got a temperature is about a pressure
and it's got a volume and I'm going
to plot here pressure and volume and I'm
going to put it dot and that's my gas.
The state of my gas is summarized
by where you put the dot
everybody. Dot. Here is a possible
state of equilibrium for the guests.
Remember the gas,
if you look at the under the hood,
it's made up of 10 to the 23 molecules.
The Real,
real state of the gas is
obtained by saying giving me
10 to the 23 locations and
tender the tender that the
velocities accordingly. Newton,
that's the maximum information
you can give me a board.
The gas right now because with that and
Newton's laws, I can predict the future,
but when you study thermodynamics,
you don't really want to
look into the details.
You want to look at gross macroscopic
properties and there are two that you need
pressure and volume. You might
say, what about temperature?
Why don't they have a
third axis for temperature?
Why is that also not a
property? Yes, for sure.
Yeah,
because PV equal to and Katie,
I don't have to give you tea if I know
pnb rather an independent thing you can
pick, you can pick P and B independently.
You cannot pick tea. Let me tell you,
by the way,
Pv was NKT is not a universal law.
It's a law that you
applied to dilute gasses,
but we are going to just
study only dilute ideal gas.
Ideal gas is one in which the atoms and
molecules are so far apart that they
don't feel any forces between
each other unless they collide.
So here's my gas sitting here.
Now what I do,
I had a few weights on top of it three
ways. I suddenly pull out one weight,
throw it out.
What do you think will happen?
But I think this gas will now shoot up.
It'll Bob up and down a few times.
Then after a few seconds or a fraction
of a second, it'll settle down,
but the new location but settled down.
I mean after a while I will
not see any macroscopic motion.
Then the gas has a new
pressure and a new volume.
It's gone from being there to being there.
What about in between?
What happened in between
starting and finishing points?
You might say, look, if it went,
if it was here in the
beginning it was there later.
It must have followed some path.
Not really.
Not In this process because if you do it
very abruptly but suddenly throwing out
one third of the weights, that's the
period when the piston rushes up.
When the gas is not in equilibrium.
By that I mean there is no single
pressure you can associate with the gas.
The bottom,
the gas doesn't even know the top is
flying off is that the old pressure in the
top of the gas is at low pressure.
So different parts of the
gas at different pressure.
We don't call that equilibrium.
So the dot representing the system
moves up the graph, it's off,
it's off the radar and only
when it is finally settled down,
the entire gas can make up its mind
on what it pressured wants to be.
We put it back here
so we have a little problem that
we have this equilibrium states,
but when you try to go from one
to another, you fly off the map,
so you want to find a device by which
you can stay on the PB diagram as you
change the state of the gas.
That brings us to the notion of
what's called a quasi static process.
It's a quasi static process is trying to
have it both ways in which you want to
change the state of the gas and you
don't want it to leave the PB diagram.
You want it to be always at equilibrium.
So what do you really want to do is not
put in three big fat blocks like this,
but instead take a guess where you
have many, many grains of sand.
They can produce the pressure though to
move one grain of sand that most a tiny
bit and very quickly settles down.
It is again true during the
tiny bit of settling down.
You didn't know what it was doing,
but you certainly named
it at the second location.
Then we'll one brain at a time.
Then you get a picture like this and you
can see where this is going or you can
make the grain smaller and smaller and
smaller and not a mathematical sense.
You can then form a continuous line.
That is to say you perform a process that
leaves the system arbitrarily close to
equilibrium,
meaning give it enough time to readjust
to the new pressure settled down to the
new volume that take another grain
and another brain and in the spirit of
calculus you can make these changes
vanishing that you can really then say it
did this.
Yes.
Pardon me? Yes, such a process.
Processes also called a,
you can call it quasi static,
but one of the features of
that, it is reversible. You
got to be a little careful.
When you say reversible,
what we mean by reversible is if I took
off a grain of sand and it came from
here to the next doc and
I put the grain back,
it'll climb back to where it was.
So you can go back and forth on this,
but now that's an idealized process
because if you had a friction,
if you had any friction between
the piston and the walls,
then if you took out the grain and it
went up, you've put the grain back,
it may not come back to quite where it is
because some of the frictional
losses you will never get back.
You cannot put Humpty dumpty back.
So most of the time processes are not
reversible. Even if you do them slowly,
if there is friction. So it's assumed
it's a completely frictionless system
cause if that is friction,
that is some heat that goes out somewhere
and some energy is lost somewhere and
we cannot bring it back if
took a frictionless piston
and on top of it it very,
very slowly you can follow this graph.
That's the kind of thermodynamic
process we're talking about.
In the old days when I studied a
single particle in the x, y plane,
I just said the guy who goes
from here to here to there,
that's very easy to study and there is
no restriction on how quickly or how fast
it moved particles.
That is no matter how quickly they
move for the thermodynamic system,
you cannot move them too fast because
they are extended and you're giving the
huge gas a single number called pressure,
so you cannot change one part of the
gas with waiting for all of them to
communicate and readjust and achieve a
global value for the new pressure and you
can move gradually that way it takes time
to drag along tender the 23 particles
as if they are the single number
two numbers characterizing them.
So we'll be studying processes like this.
Now this is called a state is the
state and one is the state. every.here.
That is a state.
No.
In every state of the system I'm
going to define a new variable,
which is called,
maybe I'll start fresh
quantity calls you.
We'd stand for the internal
energy off the gas.
Internal energy is simply the
Kennedy energy of the gas molecules,
solids and liquids. There's more
complicated formula for the gas.
Internal energy is just the
kinetic energy. And what is
that? It is three halves,
k t,
four molecule times n,
I'm sorry, three halves and Cape. Uh,
and yeah, three halves Katie. Times that
Audrey can write it as
three halves and our teeth.
Yeah,
but NRT is Pv.
Can alternate date is three house PVC.
Internal Energy's the three halves.
PV.
That means at a given
point in the PV diagram,
you have a certain internal energy. If
you're there, that's your internal energy.
Take three halves a Pv,
and that's the energy and that's
literally the kinetic energy of all the
molecules in your box.
So now I'm ready to write down what's
called the first law of thermodynamics.
Okay.
That talks about what happens if you make
a move in the PV plant from one place
to another place to go from
one place to another place.
Your internal energy will change from
u one to u two. Let's call it delta.
You,
you want ask what causes the
internal energy of the gas to change.
So you guys think about it now.
Oh that you know all about
what's happening in the cylinder.
You can ask how will I change the energy?
Well if you wanted to attend the energy
of a system that are two ways you can do
it.
One is you can do work on the gas.
Other thing is you can put the gas on a
hot plate cause if you put it on a hot
plate, we know it's going to get hotter.
It gets harder, temperature goes up.
If the temperature goes up,
the internal energy goes up.
There are two ways to
channel the energy of a gas.
The first one we call heat input.
That just means put it on something
harder and let the thing heated up.
Temperature would go up.
Notice that the internal energy of an
ideal gas depends only on the temperature.
That's something very,
very important.
I mentioned that every time I teach the
subject and some people forget and lose
a lot of points needlessly.
So I would say it once more with
feeling energy of an ideal gas.
Depends only on the temperature.
The temperature is not changed.
Energy has not changed. So probably
to remember that for what I do later.
So the change of the gas,
this cylinder full of better,
put some weights on top
and I've got gas in sight.
It can change either because I did,
I put in some heat are the gas,
did some work.
By that I mean if the gas expands,
like pushing out against the atmosphere,
then eat this. Doing the work in
Delta w is the work done by the gas?
That's where it comes to the minus sign
because it's the work done by the gas.
If you do work, you lose energy. So
what's the formula for work done?
Let's calculate that.
If you've got a piston,
here is the force times the distance,
but the force is the pressure times
the area at times the distance.
Now you guys should know enough geometry
to nor the ADF, the Piston Times,
the distance it moves is the
change in the volume we can write.
It is p times DV.
That leads to this great law.
Let me write it in a new blackboard
because we are going to be playing around
with that law.
This is law number one.
The change in the internal energy
of a system is equal to Delta Q.
Minus P. Delta V. Okay.
What does it express? It expresses
the law of conservation of energy.
It says if the energy goes up either
because you push the piston or the piston
pushed you,
then you decide what the overall sinus
[inaudible] on a hot plate we are not
equating putting it on a hot plate is
also equivalent to giving good energy
because we identify
heat as simply entered.
So if you took the piston and you nailed
the piston so it cannot move and you
put it on a hot plate PDV part we'll
manage because there is no delta B.
That's the way of heating
it is called Delta Q.
Another thing you can do is you can
terminally isolate your piston so no heat
can flow in and out of it and they
can either have the volume increase or
decrease if the gas expanded.
Delta v is positive and the PDLT minus
PW is negative and the Delta you will be
negative.
The gas bill lose energy.
That's because the molecules are beating
up on the piston and moving the piston.
I remember applying a force
doesn't cost you anything.
What if the point of application moves
you do work and who's going to pay for
the gas? It will pay for it through
it. Lots of internal energy.
Conversely,
if you push down on the Gas Delta v
will be negative and this will become
positive in the energy
of the gas would go up.
So there are two ways to change the
energy of these molecules. In the end,
all you want is one of the molecules
to move faster than before.
One is to put them on a hot
plate where that are fast moving.
When they collated the
slow moving molecules,
typically the of and sort of more faster
and the fast and sort of more slower
and therefore they'll
be transfer of Kennedy,
Canada out of any push the piston down,
you can show when a molecule
collides with the moving piston,
it will actually gain energy.
So that's how you do work to,
this is the first law.
Okay.
So let us know,
calculate the work done in a process.
We had a gas goes from here
to here on an isothermal.
Okay.
ISOTHERM is a graph of given temperature,
so this is a graph.
Pete Times would be equal to constant
because PB [inaudible] and our tea,
if t is constant, PV is a constant.
It's the rectangle of hyperbola.
The product of the x and
y coordinates is constant.
So when the x coordinate advantage
the way we'll go to infinity,
white and advantages x,
we'll go to it.
Yeah,
so you want to take your gas photo right
from here to here throughout instead of
certain temperature t
what work is done by you?
That's the video.
Nice interpretation.
The work done by you
is the integral of PDD,
but what does integral PDV
that's p and that's DV.
PDB is that shaded region.
In other words,
if it just right PDB,
it makes absolutely no sense.
If you go to a mathematician and say,
please do the integral for me,
can the mathematician do this?
What's the,
what's coming in the way of the math
addition actually doing the integral?
What do you have to not
really do an integral,
you have to know the function.
If we just said p we'll say maybe piece
constant with guess I'll pull it out of
the integral but for this problem,
because Pv is n r t and t you say constant
PE is an r t divided by V and that's
the function of the that you would need
to do the integral and if you did that
you will find is and our t all of them
are constants that come over to the
integral DV over v integrate
from the initial volume.
The final volume,
you guys know this is a logarithm,
the log of upper minus log of
low but is the log of the ratio.
This gives me an r t log be two over
v one so we have done about first work
calculation when the gas goes
on an isothermal trajectory
from start to finish,
from volume to volume v to the work done.
This is the work done by the gas.
You can all see that gas is expanding
and that's equal to the shaded region.
Okay.
By the way, I mentioned it. No,
I don't want to distract you,
but suppose later on I make it go
backwards like this. Part of the way
the work done on the going backwards
part is this area, but with a minus sign.
I hope you'll understand if you go to the
right, the Ada is considered positive.
If you go to the left area
is considered negative.
If you do the integral and put the right
limits, you'll get the right answer,
but geometrically the area under the
graph in the PB diagram is the work done.
If you're moving the direction
of increasing wallet,
if you will decrease the volume. For
example, if you just went back from here,
area looks the same but the work
done is considered negative.
You don't have to think very hard.
If you do the calculation going backwards,
you'll get log of the one over v two
they'll automatically be the negative of a
log of p two over B one but geometrically
the area under the graph is the work.
If you're going to the right,
yes.
Let's
turn
to the second stage.
Oh, this one. This will
be a graph PV equal to
essentially a constant. So you take your
gas, you see how many malls that are,
you know are,
you know the temperature.
You promise not to change
the temperature so you,
we'll move on a trajectory so
that the product PB never changes.
And in any x, y plane, if the product,
if you draw a graph that the
product x y doesn't change,
you'll have this shape contract time
that or hyperbola it just means whenever
one increases, the other should
decrease keeping the product constantly.
That's why P is proportional,
the recipe [inaudible] of the,
and you do the intake integral.
Very good.
So this is now a,
the work done by the gas.
What is the heat input?
The heat input is the change in
internal energy minus the work that uh,
let me see.
The law was Delta U is equal
to Delta Q minus Delta w yeah,
let's go back to this law.
Okay.
In this problem.
Delta w is what I just
calculated and our tea,
whatever log be two over
B one what is Delta Q?
How much heat has been put into this gas?
How do I find that?
Pardon me?
Uh,
for the heat and put you
mean? Yeah, you can use MC,
Delta t but you don't
have to do any more work.
By that I mean you don't
have to any more celebration.
What can you do with this equation
to avoid doing further calculations?
Do you know anything else?
Yes.
Yes. This is what I told you. It says
fact that people not constantly remember,
but you must,
this gas did not change its temperature.
Go back to the equation number.
Whatever I wrote down,
you equal three halves and
rt or something. He doesn't
change. Doesn't change.
That mean the initial temporary
initial internal energy. And finally,
internally the are the same
because initial templates
and final temperature the
same,
but this guy has to be zero.
That mean Delta Cube the same as Delta W
in this particular case?
Yes.
Uh, when you say Mc Delta t you got to
be careful what formula you want to use.
Uh,
I'll tell you why you
cannot use simply use MC,
Delta t if you've got a solid and you
use MC Delta t that is correct because
when you hit the solid, the heat you
put in goes into heating up the solid.
In the case of a gas, you can maybe
let's ask the following question.
His question is the following.
You're telling me you put heat into a
gas right and you say temperature doesn't
go up.
How can that possibly be?
I always thought when I put heat into
something then printed it goes up.
That's because you were thinking
about a solid red. If you put in heat,
it's got to go somewhere and of
course the temperature goes up.
What do you think is
happening to the gas here?
Think of the Piston
and weight combination.
When I want to go along
this path from here to here.
Okay.
You can ask yourself
where does the heat input and where is
the change in energy and why is that an
oil change in temperature?
If you take a piston like this,
if you wanted to increase the volume, you
can certainly take off a grain of sand,
right? If you took the grain of
sand and the piston will move up,
it will do work in that
actually it will cool down,
but that's not what you're doing.
You are keeping it on a hot plate at a
certain temperature so that if it tries
to cool down heat flows from below
to about maintaining the temperature.
So what the gas is doing in this case is
taking heat energy from below and going
there and working against
the atmosphere about it,
texting with one hand and gives out to
the other without changing his energy.
So when you were starting to specify kid,
which is my next topic,
you've got to be a little more careful
when you talk about your specific keeps
up gasses.
And I'll tell you why.
There is no single thing called
specifically for our guests that are many,
many definitions,
the depending on the circumstance.
But I hope you understand in this
case you got to visualize this.
It's not enough to draw
diagrams and rob pictures.
What did I do to the cylinder to maintain
the temperature and yet let it expand.
Expansion is going to demand
work on part of the gas.
That's going to require a loss of
energy unless you in energy from below.
So what I've done is I take green after
green so that the pressure drops in the
volume increases, but the slight
expansion would have cooled it slightly.
But the reservoir from below brings it
back to the temperature of the reservoir.
So you prop it up in temperature.
So we draw the picture by saying the gas
went from here to here and we usually
drop picture like this and say he'd
float into the system during the process.
All right, now we'll come to this question
that was raised about specific heat.
No specific Keith,
you always say is Delta Q over Delta,
t uh, over Delta t divided
by the mass of the substance.
Now we turned,
so for a gas you want it is seen that
what you want to count is not the actual
mass with the malls.
Yeah.
Because we have seen at the
level of the ideal gas law,
the energy is controlled by not simply
the mass pipe by the mall cause every
molecule gets a certain number of energy,
namely three half scape t I knew he just
wanted to count the number of molecules
or the number of malls.
Now there are many,
many ways in which you can pump in heat
into a gas and heat it up and see how
much heat it takes.
Well let's agree that we will take one
more from no one and not one kilogram
knock one kilo graph.
We'll try.
We'll find out if you do it that way.
The answer doesn't seem to depend
on the gas. That's the first thing.
Take them all off some gas
and call the specific key.
Does the energy needed to raise the
temperature of one mall by one degree?
So this should not be em.
They shouldn't be the number of malls.
So if it take one mole,
you can say,
okay one mole of gas I was told has
energy you equals three halves are t
because it was three halves and our tea.
ButN is one more.
No,
you want to put in some heat and you
really want the Delta Q over Delta t so I
remind you the Delta Q is dealt to you.
Let's be Delta beef.
Okay.
The heat input into a gas is the candy,
the energy plus p Delta v
that just from the first law.
So if I'm going to do by Delta Q
by Delta t that's the problem here.
Did you allow the volume to change or
did you not follow the volume to change?
That's going to decide
what the specific heat is.
In other words, you've been a solid is
heated. It expands at a tiny amount.
We don't worry about the work done by the
expanding solid against the atmosphere.
What for the gas when you heated,
the volume changes so much that the
worker does against the external world is
non negligible.
Therefore the specific is dependent on
what you allow the volume term to do.
So that is one definition of specific.
He'd called CV.
CV is the one at constant volume.
You don't let the volume change.
In other words,
you take the piston and you clamp it.
Now you're pumping heat from below
by putting it on a hot plate,
all the heat goes directly
to internal energy.
None of that is lost
in terms of expansion.
The Delta v Zero in that case,
Delta Q over Delta t add constant volume.
We don't know that in this fashion,
a constant volume.
This term is gone and it
just becomes belt you over.
Delta t that's very easily done.
They'll tell you what Delta
t is three over two R.
Yeah,
so the specific Keith of a gas at constant
volume is three over two are when I
started solids,
I never bothered about constant volume
because the change in the volume of a
solid is so negligible.
When there's heat it up,
it's not worth specifying that
it was a constant volume process,
but for the gas it's going to matter,
but there's constant volume or not.
Then there's a second specific
Keith people like to define
that then follows.
You take this piston,
you have some gas at some pressure you
pump in some heat but he don't clamp the
piston. The Piston expand any way
it wants at the same pressure.
For example, if we're being
pushed down by the atmosphere,
you would let the person move up if it
wants to maintaining the same pressure.
Well,
if it moves up a little bit then that it
correctly creation is the heat that you
put in is the change in internal energy
plus p times Delta v where now p is some
constant pressure.
Say the atmospheric pressure.
Delta v is the change in volume.
So Delta you needed now will be more
because you're pumping and heat from
below and you're losing energy about
because you're letting the gas expand
because you are letting the pressure be
controlled from the outside
at some fixed value.
So now Delta Q,
this delta,
you will be three over to our Delta t.
Now,
what's the change in p times?
Delta v here's where you
should know your calculus.
That p Times Change v is
the same as change in Pv.
If p is a constant, right? I remember
long back when I did rate of change,
the momentum is DVT of envy. It's
m times Dvdt. So M doesn't change.
You can take it inside the change,
but now we use PV equals Rt.
I'm talking about one more PV equals Rt.
That's a change in the quantity.
Rt is art as a constant as our times delta
t so I put in here are times Delta t.
This is the delta Q at constant pressure.
So the specific either constant pressure
is Delta Q over Delta t keeping the
pressure of constant.
You divide everything by Delta t you get
three over two r plus another r which
is fire over to ours.
So the thing you have to remember,
what I did in the end is that a gas
doesn't have a single specific heat.
You could just say put in some heat and
telling me how many calories I need to
raise the temperature.
That's not enough.
You have to tell me whether in the
interim the gas was fixed dinners,
volume or changes volume or
obey or some other condition.
The two most popular conditions people
consider are either the volume cannot
change or the pressure cannot change,
the volume cannot change.
Then the change in the heat you put in
goes directly to internal energy from the
first law of thermodynamics.
That gives you the specific
heat of three over two r.
If the pressure cannot change,
you get five over two are you can see CP
is bigger than CV because when you let
the Piston expand, then not all
the heat is going to hit the gas.
Some of it is dissipated on top
by working against the atmosphere.
Then notice that I've not
told you what gas it is.
That's where the specific heat,
but mall is the right thing to think
about because then the answer does not
depend on what particular guests you took.
There's hydrogen and helium. They all
have the same specific heat per mall.
They won't have the same
specific hip per gram, right?
Because one gram of helium and one gram
of hydrogen don't have the same number
of moles, so you have to remember
that we're talking about more.
Final thing I have to caution
you. Very, very important.
This is for a monarch atomic guests.
This is for a gas who's
Adam is the gas itself.
It's a point. It's only energy is
kinetic energy that are diatomic gases,
but two of them join together.
They can form a dumbbell or something.
Then the energy of the dumbbell has
got two parts as you learned long ago.
It can rotate around some axes
and we can also move in space.
Then the internal energy
has also got two parts.
Energy do do motion of the center
of mass and energy due to rotation.
Some molecules also vibrate
the lots of complicated things,
but if you've got only one guy,
one Adam, whatever, his masters,
it cannot rotate around itself
and it cannot vibrator on itself,
so those energies all disappear.
So we have taken the simplest one of a
mano atomic gas against whose fundamental
entities? A single atom rather
than a complicated molecule.
That's all you are responsible for.
I'll just say one thing, CP over CV.
I wanted to mention it before
you run off to do your homework.
I don't ever comes out. It's called gamma.
That's five third for a monotonic. Yes.
You can just take the
ratio of the numbers.
If in some problem you find
gamma is not five thirds, do not.
Panic just means it's a gas, which is not
monoatomic. He was not monitored Tommy.
These numbers don't have exactly those
values. We don't have to go beyond that.
We just have to know this ratio.
Gamma is five thirds in the simplest case,
but in some problem somewhere in
your life. Let me get a gamma,
which is not fight this.